le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures vient de remettre son
rapport au gouvernement à l'issue d'un
travail conséquent et de qualité je
tiens à remercier les équipes du coi
présidé par notre collègue David Valence
les annonces du gouvernement par la voix
de la première ministre la semaine
dernière marque un effort massif sur le
ferroviaire à hauteur de 100 milliards
d'euros à horizon 2040 en retenant le
scénario planification écologique comme
référence vous affirmez la volonté de
faire du ferroviaire la véritable
colonne vertébrale de la mobilité verte
cette priorité au rail se traduit par un
plan d'investissement renforcé dans le
réseau et un programme spécifique dans
les RER métropolitains les projets
prévus par la l'homme relevant du réseau
structurant et des nœuds ferroviaires
devrait être réalisés dans les délais
prévus ce qui est très attendu par nos
territoires il est à noter également que
le fluvial transport peu émetteur faire
un objet d'une attention particulière
par la régénération des voies navigables
ma première question monsieur le
ministre porte sur le financement de ce
plan d'investissement pourriez-vous nous
indiquer les pistes de travail suivi et
les montants qui pourraient être ainsi
mobilisés ma seconde question monsieur
le ministre concerne le lion Turin nous
avons apprécié dans la présentation du
coi la cohérence d'ensemble entre
l'étoile ferroviaire lyonnaise et les
accès aux tunnels de base du lion Turin
cohérence qui jusque là faisait des faux
mais je dois attirer votre attention sur
un aspect essentiel du dossier qui est
celui de la déclaration d'utilité
publique datant de 2013 qui tomberait en
2028 si l'on ne démontre pas une volonté
d'agir et de prolonger sa validité or la
question des accès semble repousser à
2038 il est donc crucial de lancer
l'étude préalable portant sur
l'avant-projet pour sécuriser
juridiquement cette DUP par ailleurs
sous le contrôle de mes collègues
j'attire votre attention sur un autre
risque majeur qui est celui des réserves
fontières faites dans le Nord Isère pour
les Accès au tunnel si la DUP venait à
tomber plus rien ne s'opposerait à la
délivrance des permis de construire sur
ce secteur rendant la réalisation des
accès impossibles je n'ose imaginer les
conséquences pour nos territoires nous
espérons donc du gouvernement des
engagements contenant de cette étude
préalable pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous rassurer sur ce point je
vous remercie